glaubst du von dir künstliche
Intelligenz von Realität unterscheiden
zu können was wenn ich dir sage dass du
auf ein Video geklickt hast dessen
thumbnail komplett von einer KI
generiert wurde alles jedes Detail mit
nur diesen Worten wir wollen uns heute
genau diese Technik für unsere Reise von
nichts zu einem Porsche zu Nutzen machen
um damit richtig Kohle zu können
herzlich Willkommen zu folge 4 von
Porsche Trailer
mit dem Golfball tauchen und der
Mietwagen Aktion konnten uns auf knapp
1.000 € hocharbeiten Problem an der
Sache keiner von diesen Jobs generiert
passives Einkommen wir machen den Job
einmal bekommen einmal Geld dafür und
genau das wollen wir heute mit AI ändern
vermutlich hat jeder von euch den
Begriff ai schon mal gehört aber was ist
das eigentlich ganz grundsätzlich ist
artificial intelligence eine Möglichkeit
menschliches Verhalten in Technologie zu
transportieren und dort zu imitieren ai
ist aber der Überbegriff der Machine
Learning und die learning zusammenfasst
im Prinzip geht es darum der Technik zu
erklären und ihr die nötigen Mittel an
die Hand zu geben sich selber weiter zu
entwickeln selber zu denken anstatt nur
ein vorgefertigtes vordefiniertes Ziel
zu erreichen das ist jetzt natürlich
sehr vereinfacht aber im Prinzip möchte
man dass die Technik selber entscheidet
sich selber weiterbildet lernt und so
weiter wie zur Hölle können wir das aber
für unsere Zwecke nutzen und vor allem
damit Geld verdienen passiv Geld
verdienen einmal eine Sache einrichten
dann laufen lassen genau das habe ich
mich die letzten Tage gefragt und sind
zu folgenden Schluss gekommen mit
journey ist gerade so mit die die Bilder
von uns erstellt auf Textbasis und gibt
also irgendwas ein und bekommt irgendwas
ausgespuckt und das in richtig kranker
Qualität
[Musik]
wir tippen imagine ein und können dann
eingeben was auch immer wir als Bild
haben wollen sowas wie cinematic
lighting picture of senior couple
Instrumen Park in Dragon in mein full
moment of meditation
das schicken wir ab wenn ihr euch fragt
warum ich so geschwollenes Englisch
geschrieben habe und dieses Bild so
genau beschrieben habe dann ist die
Antwort dass ich gar nicht selber getan
sondern dass ich Chat GPT dafür benutzt
habe mir unendlich viele verschiedene
Kombinationen an subjects also ein
Senior Kappel Office Job Firefighter
extreme sports was auch immer in
verschiedenen Lichtsituationen in
verschiedenen Szenarien ausspucken
lassen um diese in mit journey dazu
Bilder machen zu lassen und während ich
euch gerade erzählt habe wie dieser Text
zustande kam haben wir vier high quality
Bilder bekommen die von dem normalen
Foto nicht mehr zu unterscheiden sind
100% echt aus es gibt keine Glitches in
den ich dann es gibt keine Probleme in
den Bildern und das funktioniert nicht
immer aber wirklich mittlerweile in 90%
der Fällen wenn man diesen Tool die
richtigen Informationen gibt und genau
damit kommen wir zur Idee zu Kernidee
dieser Möglichkeit Geld zu verdienen wir
machen keine Fotos die wir auf Stock
Seiten verkaufen sondern lassen Fotos
von einer generieren und verkaufen sie
auf stockseiten Stock Fotos sind Bilder
die in Werbung benutzt werden auf Flyern
gedruckt werden auf irgendwelchen
Webseiten gebraucht werden einfach
Bilder die fertig sind die man im
Internet kaufen kann und die teilweise
richtig Kohle kosten und in den meisten
Fällen für Fotografen im unheimlich
aufwendig zu machen sind für uns in
diesem Fall nicht wenn wir jetzt nur
eine Möglichkeit hätten
vollautomatisiert zu gestalten selber
nichts mehr eintippen zu müssen dann
hätten wir vermutlich gefunden was geht
Bro ich bin auf der Suche nach einem
oder hallo ich meine mich zu erinnern
dass du mal jemanden hattest der dir die
ganzen Minecraft Projekte gekotet hat in
heißen oder in welcher
Programmiersprache auch immer abwarten
und Tee trinken
hallo danke
[Musik]
es scheint als hätten wir einen Cola was
soll ich sagen es kannte jemand einen
Code ein Coder direkt aus Köln mit dem
ich gesprochen habe und der ziemlich
pampfer über die Idee innerhalb von 24
Stunden hat Leon so heißt der Coda ein
Python Script gebaut dass diesen
gesamten Prozess vollautomatisiert und
das meine lieben Freunde war meine erste
Reaktion auf das tatsächlich
funktionierendes
Alter das haben wir uns alles nicht mal
selber ausgedacht ich halte dicker ich
mache alle zwei Sekunden Kamera wieder
an welche komplett geflasht bin guck mal
hier einfach auf random gerade so ein
Foto von dem Golfplatz gekommen
Schicksal Leon was macht der Code
überhaupt und wir fragt automatisiert
nach jeweils 100 Bildbeschreibungen die
sind zufällig ausgedacht diese
Bildbeschreibung nehmen wir dann locken
uns über discord ein und schicken
automatisiert jede einzelne Beschreibung
an mit journey mit journey macht daraus
immer jeweils vier Forscher Bilder nach
20 bis 30 Sekunden gestellt und dann
lass mich alle mal rausrennen Qualität
das doch nochmal 10 Sekunden und danach
alle automatisch downloadet man nur noch
hochladen muss
ach du scheiße
what the [__] all diese ey Eis haben
APIs das sind im Prinzip Schnittstellen
an die man sich mit einem Code dran
klemmen kann quasi wie offene Türen wo
Daten rein und rausgenommen werden um
das komplett vereinfacht zu erklären
damit man nicht wirkliche Klicks auf der
Website imitieren muss sondern quasi
viel kleinere Datenpakete hin und her
schiebt und bewegen muss um das selbe
Ergebnis zu erzeugen das macht den
Prozess viel schneller viel einfacher
weniger Daten intensiv und genauso haben
wir es gemacht und das fühlt sich immer
noch obwohl ich jetzt schon seit ein
paar Tagen weiß dass der Code
funktioniert verboten gut an also
wirklich verboten gut
stand jetzt exportieren wir gerade vier
Bilder die Minute 4 die man eigentlich
alle mit dem Fotoapparat hätte machen
müssen importieren bearbeiten
exportieren lassen wir gerade
vollautomatisch vier hochqualitative
Bilder pro Minute exportieren das sind
240 Bilder die Stunde und 5760 Bilder in
24 Stunden auf eine Woche gerechnet
läuft der Bot also durch kommen wir bei
40.320 Bildern raus sitzt davon nur ein
Prozent ein Prozent der wirklich so gut
ist dass er gekauft werden würde würden
wir 43 Bilder rausbekommen innerhalb von
einer Woche ohne irgendwas dafür zu tun
was völlig Banane ist und wenn wir uns
die Sachen angucken die gerade
ausgespuckt werden dann sieht es genauso
aus als könnte es wirklich funktionieren
also im Endeffekt funktioniert bis dato
wirklich alles vollautomatisch außer
dass wir die Bilder wirklich hochladen
auf dem Plattform wo wir damit Geld
verdienen können das liegt zum einen
daran dass unser Account erstmal
verifiziert werden muss weil die
Plattform bestätigen muss dass die
Qualität an Bildern die wir hochladen
wirklich gut ist dass sie was damit
anfangen können und zum anderen daran
dass das ein bisschen krampfig ist das
gerade noch einzustellen wir kümmern uns
aber darum und es wird in Zukunft auch
noch passieren es könnten uns noch
Probleme in den Weg kommen wie dass die
Plattform unsere Bilder nicht haben
wollen weil manche Plattform wollen das
nicht dass die Leute sich auf unsere
Bilder nicht kaufen wollen aber wir
haben natürlich die Proms genau in
Richtung gebaut wo wir wissen dass
häufig stockbilder gekauft werden also
Sachen aus dem Office Hochzeitsfotos
irgendwelche Technologie und wie a
Sachen ganz viel so Kram und es ist
perfekt darauf ausgelegt dass wir damit
wirklich Geld verdienen können und das
haben wir auch also wir haben nicht viel
Geld verdient aber es wurde schon Geld
verdient grundsätzlich müssen wir gerade
die Bilder noch händisch auf eine
Plattform hochladen die die Bilder dann
auf allen Stock Seiten verteilen also
einmal hochladen auf zehn verschiedenen
Stock Seiten werden die Bilder dann
angezeigt problematisch an der Sache wir
können gerade nur 100 Bilder hochladen
die dann prüft werden die auch schon und
ruft sind und danach wird unser Account
freigeschaltet das wird tausende vom
Bilder hochladen können und trotzdem
haben wir schon Geld verdient aber wir
haben auch Geld ausgegeben insofern
gesagt wir haben mehr Geld ausgegeben
als wir verdient haben 10
$ für mit journey pro Mitgliedschaft
damit wir mehr und schneller und bessere
Bilder erzeugen können kostenlos weil
bei uns neu mit einer neuen Handynummer
angemeldet haben und Leon kostet um es
30 Prozent vom Gewinn also kostet nicht
direkt Geld sondern nur wenn Geld
wirklich verdient wird und wir haben uns
sogar einigt weil es meine tolle Idee
war und seine schöne Umsetzung wie viel
wir aber genau verdient haben und wie
viel wir in Zukunft verdienen werden
weil das ganze ja genau darauf ausgelegt
ist dass wir über Zeit und zwar jeden
Tag und jede Nacht und immer weiter Geld
verdienen werdet ihr in den nächsten
Videos erfahren vergesst also nicht den
Kanal zu abonnieren um zu erfahren ob
daraus tatsächlich was wird lass dem
Video ein Like da wenn euch das Video
und die Idee gefallen hat dann sehen wir
uns nächste Woche Sonntag zu einer
weiteren Folge von Porsche Trailer
wieder
sogar